[Music]
sophia richie and scott disick are still
going strong on Sunday the 19 year old
model and her reality star beau attended
the American Idol finale taping to
support Sophia's dad Lionel Richie who
is a judge on the music competition show
it's a big deal I couldn't miss it for
the world
Scott kept it casual in a NASA hoodie
cargo pants and a pair of sneakers while
Sophia rocked an oversized fuzzy coat
crop top and a pair of white boots
before the cameras started rolling Sofia
made sure to give her dad a big hug she
shared this shot on Instagram writing
support team Sofia and Scott have been
dating since May 2017 and in November
2017 the teens famous dad opened up to
et about his daughter's relationship all
you have to do is understand phases
don't get involved make you comment keep
a straight face don't get involved and
sure enough it's always the person you
want to be with your daughter or your
son they don't pick those
as always the person they fall in love
with and you go
be calm just be calm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]